وسائل التجسس من اليعسوب للمنطاد
وسائل التجسس التي اقلقت دولا حول العالم
وارعبتها فما بين الغواصات والصراصير
وحشرات اليعسوب مرورا بالهاكرز وصولا الى
هذا المنطاد الصيني الذي اتهمته امريكا
بمراقبه مواقع استراتيجيه على اراضيها قبل
ان تنهي امره بصاروخ من مقاتله اف 22
سقطت ادوات تجسس قد لا تخطر على بال احد
في قبضه اجهزه الاستخبارات مثل حشره
اليعسوب التي سميت بذرون الحرب البارده
ففي عام 70 استخدمت وكاله الاستخبارات
المركزيه الامريكيه جهاز تنصت على شكل
حشره اليعسوب هذا الجهاز استطاع الطيران
على ارتفاع
1998 مترا ولمده 60 ثانيه كان اول روبوت
صغير الحجم تم استخدامه في مهام تجسسيه
بالحرب البارده تعرض سي اي اي في متحفها
الخاص ادوات تجسس يسبق لها مثيل من بينها
جهاز تنصت صمم ليبدو وكانه براز نمر كان
يسجل التحركات القوات في فيتنام اضافه الى
سمكه الروبوت ثم اليعسوب الصغير
الحشرات والطيور وحيوانات اخرى استخدمت في
عمليه التجسس لكن كيف يمكن للثلاجه او
السياره ان تتنصت علينا المرعب في سجلات
التجسس بين الصين وامريكا هو ما كشفه
دبلوماسي بريطاني سابق يدعى للحكومه
البريطانيه في تقرير شديد اللهجه يحذر فيه
من قدره بكين على التجسس على ملايين
الاشخاص من خلال ما وصفه بسلاح الرقائق
الدقيقه المدمجه في الاف الادوات والاليات
من السيارات الى الاجهزه المنزليه وحتى
المصابيح الكهربائيه والثلاجات وطبعا
اجهزه الكمبيوتر المحموله
الاجهزه المصنعه في الصين تحوي رقائق اي
او تي اس الخلويه وهي وحدات صغيره تستخدم
في كل شيء من الثلاجه الذكيه الى انظمه
الاسلحه المتقدمه لمراقبه ونقل البيانات
الى المالك وغالبا الى الشركه المصنعه عبر
استخدام تقنيه 5 جي
ادوات التجسس تتنوع حسب الفتره الزمنيه
ومدى تطورها التكنولوجي فالمنطاد الصيني
الذي اسقطته الولايات المتحده تسلح
بالذكاء الاصطناعي وخبراء قالوا انه من
الممكن ان هذا المنطاد حمل تقنيات توجيه
لم يتم اعتمادها بعد لدى الجيش الامريكي
وهو ما جعل الولايات المتحده غير مستعده
لتسليم حطام هذا المنطاد الى بكين
نعم ستطلب الصين اعاده الحطب وسيكون ردنا
على الارجح لن نعيد حطام المنطار وسنجمعه
من اجل فحصه بسبب القيمه الاستخباراتيه
التي يتمتع بها بالنسبه لنا
لن يتوقف التجسس بين الدول او عليها طالما
ان الصراع على الهيمنه على العالم مستمر
في ظل سباق غير معهود في التسلح
التكنولوجي خصوصا بين اكبر قوتين
اقتصاديتين على الكوكب امريكا والصين لكن
السؤال الابرز هنا هل يدشن هذا المنطاد
عصر الحرب البارده بين البلدين ام ان
الامر سيحل دبلوماسيا وينتهي